Katka Buddha may blue be purchase key
chest you know yeah they're nice him
Ruby really just you know
welcome
Raoh post lady lady factory yeah same
studio Val who claims to know
[Music]
Postino College to note actress proton
teach car yeah just go move it just keep
Molly
don't even say is a yes leap boo digit
just just carry Pulitzer mm Nikolic mess
it's a legend Nash moment Arnie
let's read she never let you know let's
go Bonnie Raj mom Nikolic pretty like do
what a proper way Kelvin piri-piri yeah
mmm how do you say Oona's blink mommy
well meet object debris debris of shock
lecture gnashing bibliothèque today
oh yeah let me do legit a boy yes the
name um don't be a mom
honey let me don't be like see progress
let's go that's Gino / - hey yeah mmm
miss Lim Djibouti not too bad
visit not Israel Israel Israel the
months forget it what yeah nasty what
[Music]
clicker
yeah Cellucci red let you know every
Thursday every simulation Oh No
a boy named Ahmed
dobri observe don't relax yet bro
Arabs Janu every every few no Ali Molly
don't be absurd bro yes'm Rosado Sachi
not which it's a no-no ten-year pit nuts
she's not touch connect Mnemosyne reach
yeah mmm
love it Romans do zapping ahh zapping
Ali chromhmm
oh no I think we're frozen here okay
we're back No
moist you know sectional yes Ikki
three yeah Sam Oh chill some hoppin ruin
la Ruche denote Isabel Toby
pretty pretty sure she knows if a
strictly a pretty reflect they may see
there is yeah yes that okay
finish off an English here no I know
like I haven't spoken check right and so
I'm sometimes searching in there is this
is this Ukrainian missus Jack gives us
Russian whatever but you know one thing
I believe and maybe that's something
that we can finish up with here is I
think when you speak languages and I'm
sure you'll agree you'll have to trust
yourself you have to trust yourself you
have to trust that something will come
out that may not always be right but
just go with it
you know go with it if I'm saying geez I
haven't spoken check in a few years and
I'll get it all wrong and is this writer
is that right forget it
maybe I said something that was polish
or her cranium Russian it doesn't matter
you have to trust yourself
and and you're gonna it's like riding a
bicycle you can't be thinking about what
do i do on this bicycle or swimming you
just have to trust yourself and and i
think that if you learn a language
through massive input and this is why my
romanian basically i had two months
before I went to Romania that's just not
enough I mean with Czech and I spent a
whole year if my statistics at links say
that I have 60,000 words that doesn't
mean that I have all these words but
it's an indication of the amount of
reading and listening that I did in
Czech and if you ingest so much of the
language it's not gonna go away that's
nice that's my bit I play even
especially comprehensive I I wish you a
very successful conference I'm sorry
that I can't be there are you gonna be
in Bratislava by the way I hope so okay
yes liked me okay good and I hope I know
you have a little bit of a cold and your
kids have a cold so I hope that you all
get well soon and thank you but how do
you say you're welcome again
I can't approach him know the answer
okay bye for now
[Music]